ganz klar ist diese corona-zeit das war
Herr Christian für ganz vielen
Spießrutenlauf viele Menschen fühlten
sich weggedrängt fühlten sich als
corona-kritiker an den Rand gedrängt
eine Partei muss man sagen wie ist er
deutlich gegen den Strom geschwommen in
dieser Zeit die wird jetzt zehn und das
obwohl sie schon mehrfach tot gesagt
wurde die AFD steht jetzt beim Bund bei
rund
12%, und sie sagen dass ist auch den
etablier etablierten Parteien zu
verdanken das ist ihr Thema jetzt ja die
AFD AFD die Alternative für Deutschland
wurde vor 10 Jahren gegründet die
Glückwünsche vielen sehr spärlich aus
die Frage die mich allerdings doch
stellen muss warum gibt es sie und warum
gibt es sie immer noch und diese Frage
kann ich mit einem Satz hier beantworten
die AFD füllt die Lücken die die anderen
Parteien lassen und zwar von Anfang an
2013 hat Frau Merkel gesagt die Rettung
des Euro und die Euro Rettungspakete
sind alternativlos dann haben
Wirtschaftsleute gesagt nein das ist
nicht alternativlos wir müssen nicht mit
Milliarden deutschen Steuergeld in Euro
retten und schwuppdiwupps statt eine
Alternativen losen Politik gab es eine
Alternative für Deutschland den Namen
nach 20 14 stand die fast schon wieder
vor dem Aus es gab jede Menge Austritte
und aus der Hebamme Frau Merkel wurde
dann die Krankenschwester Frau Merkel
die nämlich lebenserhaltende Maßnahmen
am Leib der siechen AFD Vornamen durch
ihre willkommenspolitik durch ihre
Entscheidung die Grenzen nicht zu
schließen die Grenzen offen zu lassen
bildete sich ein neuer Kern von Wählern
und Politikern die sagten nein ich will
nicht einstimmen in diese
Willkommenskultur in diese Pflicht sowie
Willkommenskultur gewissermaßen und wer
da nicht mitmacht wurde auch gefremd als
schlechter Demokrat oder als rechter
Eckensteher und heute das gleiche wieder
wir haben große Probleme mit der
migrationsintegration und Asylpolitik
wir haben fast Rekord hohe Asyl
Erstanträge jetzt gehabt im Januar 2023
und alle die Politiker alle anderen
Parteien sagen wir müssen die
Flüchtlinge einfach besser verteilen wir
müssen bauen
und werden gesagt wie beispielsweise AFD
wir brauchen ein zuzugsmoratorium wir
müssen schauen dass weniger kommen dafür
uns erstmal und die kümmern können die
da sind der findet eben momentan außer
der AFD niemanden der diese Meinung
vertritt insofern muss ich sagen die AFD
ist das schlechte Gewissen der anderen
Parteien sie ist das laute schrille Balk
von Angela Merkel und sie wird genauso
lange bleiben wie die anderen Parteien
diese Themenfelder innere Migration
Flüchtlingen Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Integration vielleicht auch Islamismus
nicht aufgreifen also noch einmal die
AFD ist das schlechte Gewissen der
anderen Parteien der Name ist konkret
dann müsste eigentlich die CDU einfach
weiter nach rechts rücken und dann
ja sie müsste zumindest mal erkennen
dass dort ein Problem gibt teilweise
wird es ja probiert ich kann jetzt keine
einzigen Partei verraten die
Lösungsvorschläge der AFD zu übernehmen
ist ja klar dann politischer Wettbewerb
aber man kann einfach nicht so tun zu
sagen dass eben alle Menschen die jetzt
im Ort demonstrieren gegen ein noch mal
zusätzlich gebautes Flüchtlingsheim die
sich fragen warum werden immer mehr Geld
ausgegeben für immer mehr Flüchtlinge
werden gleichzeitig die Renten weniger
werden die Schwimmbäder geschlossen
werden da kann ich sagen die sind alle
rechts und rechtsextreme man macht die
gewissermaßen zu Recht und zu recht
extrem wenn man sagt es gilt nur eine
Meinung ist deswegen Corona wer da
ausgeschert ist der war dann gleich ein
Leugner ein Schwuler wer hier sagt Stopp
momentan schaffen wir das nicht mehr da
ist ein rechtsextremer und die AFD macht
auf grelle weiße auf teilweise
systemische auf strategische
populistische Weise auch muss ja keiner
gut finden aber sie nimmt diese Themen
auf und sie gibt ihnen einen Raum
innerhalb des Parteien Spektrums und
diese Raum wäre natürlich kleiner wenn
dieses Problem von allen anderen
Parteien erkannt worden wäre als Problem
zumindest und ich werfe das auch Olaf
vor ich habe mir viele Reden von ihm
angehört ein Thema was er nie anspricht
ist innere Sicherheit innere Sicherheit
ist bei der SPD als Themenfeld fast
nicht vorhanden dabei muss man sagen
gerade wenn wir die Interessenvertreter
sind der kleinen Leute der Angestellte
der Handwerker müssen wir uns um innere
Sicherheit kümmern weil die können nicht
im Porsche davon fahren oder sich
schönen Willen verstecken die brauchen
Sicherheit auf den Straßen Tag und Nacht
also innere Sicherheit müsste eigentlich
auch in Essen sein der SPD stattdessen
sagt die SPD die AFD muss auf alle
Zeiten Paria bleiben verstehe ich aber
sie wird garantiert dadurch nicht
sympariert dass man ihre Themen negiert
und auch die FDP grenzt sich ab und
überlässt somit zu viele Themen der AFD
ich meine 22 13 ganz kurz so 20 13 €
Rettungspolitik da hat die FDP sich
gegen den Kurs damals von Herrn
Scheffler dieser glaube ich entschieden
hat hat ein quotium innerhalb der Partei
verloren wir machen da nicht mehr mit
bei diesen Euro Rettungsmechanismus und
das hat mit Ende ist ein Impuls für für
locker und und die Kollegen die AFD zu
gründen also damals
dass wir nicht mehr registriert haben
und kapitaler Fehler ne also darüber
müssen wir reden wir brauchen da Ansätze
und es darf auch nicht sofort in den
rechten Raum geschickt werden ich habe
erst vor kurzem Sicherheit ich habe im
oktoben Thema
ich habe erst im Oktober zum Beispiel
beim Thema Aufnahme gesagt wir brauchen
muratorium hier in Berlin weil wir das
gerne mal abdecken können
Sie sich gerne mal zu uns in den setzen
Sie sich doch mal gerne zu uns in den
Ausschuss und hören Sie sich doch an
wenn man solche Vorschläge macht wie
schnell man dann relativ schnell im
rechten Ecke ist also ich glaube wir
haben halt auch verlernt dass wir uns
ernsthaft mit dem Thema auseinander
werden die Probleme immer immer jeden
Tag in den in die Rechtecke das ist ja
das lässt sich dahin treiben alles was
sie AFD anfasst und manche Sachen sind
davon gar nicht so schlecht an sich
allgemein innere Sicherheit Migration
das will man nicht mehr anfassen auch
die FDP die da total einknickt und bei
der SPD mein Kollege schon richtig
gesagt da findet sich Sicherheit
eigentlich faktisch gar nicht mehr statt
es ist eher mehr eine Symbolpolitik man
sieht das bei Innenminister unseren
Feser wir haben eine extreme
migrationskrise seit 2016 sind die
Zahlen nicht mehr so hoch wie sie jetzt
sind was hat denn in diesem Jahr wo es
wirklich von Monat zu Monat sich
gesteigert hat wo jetzt auch im Januar
und sehen die neuesten Zahlen das ist
weitergeht die migrationskrise Januar
ist eigentlich ein schwacher Monat es
geht weiter auch über die Schweiz was
hat denn im Ministerin Weser getan sie
hatten flüchtlingsgipfel gemacht daraus
ergab sich eigentlich praktisch nichts
dann hat sie eine Aktionsplan an der
Grenze zur Schweiz gemacht der
eigentlich auch gar nichts bedeutet weil
man kann nur an einem Punkt ganz
Kontrollen machen dann kommen die
einfach über andere Wege
Asyl ist ein Menschenrecht aber wir sind
gerade an einem Punkt in Deutschland wo
wir begrenzte Kapazitäten haben wo alle
Landräte und viele Minister sagen wir
können gerade nicht mehr wir brauchen
eine Lösung wir brauchen auch eine
Begrenzung weil wir können nicht über
200.000 Menschen jedes Jahr aufnehmen
natürlich jeder der der flieht vor
politischer verfolgen zum Beispiel
natürlich muss der hier also übertragen
können das ist Menschenrecht aber wir
müssen doch darüber reden was auch
Menschen versorgen haben wie wir es
jetzt in vielen vielen Städten Dörfern
Bundesländer erleben und das findet
eigentlich auch bei der FDP nicht statt
und dann überlassen Sie dieses Thema der
arztprogramm Vorbeigehen
dann lassen Sie mich das doch mal
erklären wir müssen zum Beispiel doch
bei dem Thema dann über die Geschichte
Einwanderung Einwanderungsrecht
Aufenthaltsrecht Arbeitserlaubnis zum
Beispiel sprechen also wenn ich Leute
hier ins Land hole oder Leute hier ins
Land kommen da muss ich ihn entweder
eine Perspektive geben
oder keine Perspektive geben aber das
sind wir glaube ich die Partei die seit
Jahren sagt dass wir nach kanadischen
vorbitten einfach nahrungsrecht brauchen
in der Frage das ist bei uns seit ich
weiß seit zehn Jahren Beschlusslage
verweigert hat sich die Union der
Diskussion die bis heute der Meinung ist
wir schaffen es dass wir keinen
Einwanderungsland sind das werden wir
wirtschaftlich allein schon gar nicht
schaffen aber die Frage ist doch welche
Perspektive machen wir auf damit komme
ich auch auf das Thema Asyl und und und
und Flucht natürlich müssen wir sowas
wie Dublin in der europäische Lösung
wieder fordern also
Christian Lindner war in den letzten
Jahren nicht Bundeskanzler also und das
ist relativ einfach im Bundestag
passiert
ja die sorgt z.B auch für Anreize das
ist noch mehr Menschen kommt
wenn man das Einwanderungsrecht hat wenn
man zum Beispiel genau die richtigen
Punkte was wollen wir denn an Menschen
in diesem Land das ist doch völlig
richtig dass ich jetzt hochqualifizierte
gute Menschen in den in der Situation wo
wir einen Arbeitskraft einfach haben
Fachkräftemangel wir haben doch gerade
angesprochen FDP ganz oft tut jetzt in
letzter Zeit dass sie
illegale Migration mit Fachkräftemangel
vermischt da müssen wir aufpassen ich
meine es ist natürlich auch so und das
muss natürlich der AFD vorwerfen das ist
natürlich immer ein sehr schön ein
hysterischen ein sehr auf Untergang
gestimmten Ton anschlägt ich habe noch
mal alte Debatten angeschaut aus der
Anfangsphase der corona-pandemie von
Frau Weidel im Bundestag die weiß ich
sicher also drei Monate später sind im
Prinzip alle Läden zu und den Euro
gibt's gar nicht mehr weil wir alle
wirtschaftlich koten so schlimm gab es
ja auch nicht also ja AFD steht sich mit
schrillen Forderungen mit teilweise
unklaren Abgrenzungen zum radikalen Rand
mit einer dubiosen Russland Nähe
natürlich auch selber im Weg das ist ja
völlig klar aber die anderen Parteien
müssten ebenso verräten sein diese
Mädchen nicht mitzumachen und diesen
schrillen Ton von den Themen zu
abstrahieren die damit angeschlagen
werden und vor allen Dingen nicht die
vielleicht aus Mangel an Alternativen
die Alternative Deutschland wählen in
einen Topf zu stecken ich meine man kann
nicht allen Menschen vorwerfen ihre Wahl
entscheiden und zu sagen ja das zählt
irgendwie weniger weil du willst eine
Partei die irgendwie bäh ist man muss
den wahlentscheid der einzelnen Bürger
ernst nehmen die Anliegen die hinter dem
Wahl entscheidend steht man sagt ja
manchmal ein Schreiner Liebe jeder
wahlentscheid ist irgendwie so ein
Schrei nach Liebe und den muss man auch
ernst nehmen und darf diese Menschen die
sie wählen die nochmal von den
funktionieren zu trennen sich sind nicht
komplett aus dem demokratischen Diskurs
aus und Einsatz ist das eben fast alle
im Bundestag sagen ja alle
demokratischen Parteien hier sind sich
einig und das meint dann alle außer der
AFD der möchte ich sagen also keine
demokratische Verfahren durchläuft der
dürfte gar nicht im Bundestag sitzen
also das sind so kostenlose gratis
Gewinner der Moral wenn Sie das
Diskussionen zueinander möchte ich gerne
Ihre Meinung als Bürger hier sitzen
Journalisten ein Politiker wie wirkt das
auf sie werden zu viele Themen quasi
nicht angefasst von den etablierten
Parteien weil man sich nicht trauen ja
muss ich wieder zurück in die in die
pandemiezeit es wäre am schönsten
gewesen wenn die AFD gesagt hat wir
brauchen eine Impfpflicht dann wäre die
wahrscheinlich gar nicht gekommen hätte
die AFD gesagt wir brauchen eine
maskenpflicht dann wäre die
maskenpflicht ganz sicher nicht gekommen
und genau das ist es übel nein das meine
ich im Ernst ich weiß das klingt
irgendwie lustig aber im Prinzip ist es
so die AFD gibt ein Stöckchen also ein
Thema vor und die anderen hüpfen drüber
indem sie aber dann nicht mehr anfassen
weiß eben verbrannt ist weil man Angst
hat dass man in die AFD nee gerückt wird
aufgrund des Themas und da kann ja auch
selbst aber Elite von Singen also wenn
ich irgendwie gesagt die Maßnahmen sind
es schlecht oder oder die die Körper
besser machen und der AFD ähm
Landtagsabgeordneter oder Politiker hat
es aufgenommen dann war mein Kritikpunkt
erledigt und das ärgert mich natürlich
auch als Bürger denn das kann ich in der
ganzen Politik verfolgen und den Fehler
sollten die Politiker nicht machen man
darf natürlich die Dokumente der AFD
aufnehmen natürlich darf man das machen
warum denn nicht die AFD ist
demokratisch legitimiert die ist gewählt
wo gerade ist verfasst und demokratisch
gefährlich ja also das haben Bürger in
Deutschland haben gewählt und das muss
man schon ernst nehmen man muss sie also
die AFD man muss sie nicht mögen aber
man muss sich mit ihr auseinandersetzen
sollte es anders werden
Auseinandersetzung findet nicht statt
indem ich einfach die Themen von der AFD
nicht mehr aufgreifen